por segundo día consecutivo el personal
de salud de Reino Unido mantuvo su
huelga en casi todo el territorio
levantando nuevas protestas en distintos
puntos del país luego de que el gobierno
de Regis unak presentara un proyecto
para que los trabajadores presten un
servicio mínimo algo que aumentó el
malestar entre los trabajadores que hace
días se encuentran en disputa con el
gobierno reclamando mejoras en sus
salarios y condiciones laborales
el secretario de estado ahora lo tiene
muy claro mantiene que resolver esta
disputada no va a ser hablar de salarios
para el futuro sino hacer mejoras en el
año de pago actual hacernos una oferta
de mejora antes del primero de abril
hemos sido muy claros al respecto el
secretario de estado ha reconocido esta
posición
este miércoles sunat manifestó su
preocupación ante las consecuencias de
un paro al que se hirieron alrededor de
25.000 trabajadores incluyendo
paramédicos Y ambulancias en este clima
de tensión miles de ambulancias fueron
operadas por unidades militares para
mantener el servicio
lo que es aterrador es que ahora mismo
las personas no saben si cuando llaman
al nueve nueve nueve recibirán el
tratamiento que necesita
ahora señor presidente en Australia
Canadá y en Estados Unidos prohibieron
las huelgas en los servicios de Luz Azul
no estamos haciendo eso todo lo que
decimos es que en estos servicios de
emergencia los pacientes deberían poder
contar con un nivel básico de atención
que le salve la vida
Reino Unido está transitando un
levantamiento de trabajadores en varios
sectores a medida que los aumentos
salariales no logran mantenerse al día
con una inflación que alcanza los dos
dígitos y máximas de los últimos 40 años